there's a new trailer for the next Dune
movie it reveals the emperor of the
universe shadam Carino it shows
surprising tensions between Charlie and
Paul and it explores the story's theme
of political and religious Messiahs so
what happens in the trailer and how does
it compare to the Dune book this video
has no big spoilers for the movie just
some background information to prepare
us for Dune part 2.
the trailer begins with the sun and
moons of arrakis this sun is called
cannabis which is a real star it's the
second brightest star in the earth's
night sky so cannabis has mythical
significance in many real world cultures
and is referenced in many other sci-fi
stories arrakis has two moons and the
larger Moon has a shape on it that looks
like a human hand while the smaller Moon
has a shape that looks like a kind of
kangaroo mouse found on a rackus called
muord Deep we saw the MUA deep Mouse
three times in the first movie The
fremin admire muadib for its ability to
survive in the desert so there's a
constellation named after the mouse that
Points North muadib is a guide to the
foramen and as we see in this trailer
Paul takes muadib as his name as he too
becomes a guide and a leader to the
foramen Paul says this world is beyond
cruelty the environment of arrakis is
Harsh so to survive the fremin learned
to withstand suffering and to make
brutal judgments like in the first movie
when the fremen were gonna kill Paul and
Jessica to take their water in the
desert brutality and suffering aren't
good or bad they're not cruel they're
just necessary to survive so in that
sense arrakis is beyond cruelty we see
Paul's hand on the sand which is just
like a vision Paul had in the first
movie Dune explores how people change
environments and how environments change
people so how will this harsh
environment change Paul
we see a Hawken and gunship firing maybe
attacking some framing the ships in
these movies have organic curving shapes
inspired by Nature like this ship was
based on the shape of an armadillo this
Harvester looks like a Sinister squid or
spider this gunship was inspired by
Bubonic plague infections and gangrenous
tumors as the harkinons are a sickness
an infection on this land director
dannyville nov calls the harkenans
Invaders colonizers and predators the
bulging shape of the hovering ship also
looks like the fat levitating Baron
Vladimir harkenen we see the baron and
base raban with a harkenen army there's
more Sinister hungry looking harken and
architecture behind them reminiscent of
the old H.R Giga June concept art this
place might be carthag the harkenen city
on arrakis which is 200ks from arakene
the small smaller older city where the
Atreides settled it looks like the baron
has some floating Globes attached to him
maybe this is a medical device like a
Sci-Fi IV drip because remember the
baron was poisoned in the first movie
maybe he's still recovering in the first
movie The Baron told Rabanne to kill all
the fremin maybe that's what this Army
is for but killing all fremin won't be
easy we learned in the first movie that
the fremin are much more numerous and
more powerful than the hakunans realize
and now Paul and Jessica have joined the
foramen Paul says the fremen have fought
the hearkenans for decades because the
hearkenans ruled Iraqis for 80 years
before the Atreides took over but the
Atreides of Fort harkenens for centuries
because these two families have hated
each other for 10 000 years ever since
the Battle of Corin this battle is when
house Carino Rose to power the ancestors
of Emperor shaddam and Princess era on
established their empire and after this
battle and a trades got a hearkenen
banished for cowardice starting a blood
Feud that continues to this day the
baron wants to finally win this ancient
Conflict by Exterminating the Atreides
he also wants to cover up that the
emperor helped the hakanans with his
sadakar soldiers because if the other
houses find out that the emperor helped
attack the Atreides the houses would all
turn against shaddam so that might be
why the hearkenans burned these corpses
destroying the evidence we see Paul
reflecting on the death of his father
later Paul now has lato's juicul cygnus
ring because in the first movie yui took
this ring from lato and got it to Paul
because the ring represents the
leadership of house a trades with later
dead Paul is now the Duke and the ten
thousand year a tradies dynasty is now
his responsibility can he defeat the
enemies who killed his father we see a
religious painting of lato because the
prophecy of the lisan al-ghaib or Mahdi
suggests that Paul is a messiah who will
save the foramen and Paul's parents
later and Jessica are also considered
sacred in the book Paul has visions of a
shrine with his father's skull and you
can see the teeth of later's skull Atop
The Shrine here in the Visions this
skull Shrine feeds the fanaticism of a
holy war so Paul's parents are not just
important to Paul personally his family
has profound religious and political
significance to this planet we see a
fight scene where Paul and Charney wait
to Ambush some Harkin and soldiers in
the desert Paul grabs an enemy sword and
kills a hearkenen with a cool spin move
Jessica kills a hearkenen with a rock we
also see this huge battle with chani
fighting against the Emperor's sardica
this shot looks like a vision Paul had
in the first movie of himself fighting
sardica Paul shouts charney's name as
though he's distressed to see his love
swept up in the violence that he foresaw
in the book we don't see Paul or Jessica
or Charney fighting random soldiers we
do hear about some fights and battles
that happen off screen like it's
mentioned that Paul goes on raids with
the fremin and chani has a badass moment
but we don't see these fights happen in
the book because the book is focused on
thoughts conversations Visions plans and
politics the book is less about sword
fights and more about battles of the
mind of course it's difficult to show
thoughts on a screen and that's part of
why June is so hard to adapt into a
movie so Dune part 2 is adding new fight
scenes and explosions to make this an
action-packed war movie a visual spec
critical but hopefully it won't lose the
thoughtful tone and the meaning of the
book because June is not about violence
June is about the power of the Mind
in the trailer Paul and Charlie attack a
spice Harvester maybe they're disrupting
Harkin and spice mining like at the
start of the first movie chani uses a
big weapon to blow up an ornithopter
which is similar to a bit in the book
Paul gives the fremin Rockets to use
against enemy aircraft you can see this
explosion contained within the thopter's
shield for a moment maybe this weapon
shoots a slow projectile that can pass
through a shield before exploding like
the slow bombs we saw in the first movie
we see fremin climbing under the spice
Harvester maybe to plant explosives or
steal spice Paul jumps onto Charney
maybe to protect her from that gun we
saw in the first trailer remember in the
Dune Universe people usually don't use
guns because most soldiers have shields
that block bullets making guns useless
but fremin don't use Shields because on
arrakis Shields attract sand worms and
shields are often disabled by electrical
storms so in the book The hearkenings
realized that since framing don't use
Shields they can use guns and Laz guns
against them but the fremen have their
own advantages like they are great
Fighters and they know this land they
can use Guerrilla tactics against the
hearkenans Striking then disappearing
into hidden caves and the fremin now
have Paul on their side in the trailer a
fremant tells Paul you're not welcome
here because there are many different
fremant tribes on arrakis stilgar's
group May accept Paul but other fremin
may not the Dune books explores some
unusual and extreme fremin subcultures
like the legendary iduwali of jacaruto
so how will Paul and Charney deal with
fremin who oppose him chani goes to
translate the fremens words to Paul but
Paul interrupts and says he already
understands thanks it's a moment of
slightly sarcastic humor from Paul in
the book Paul is usually serious
stressed haunted by visions high on
spice walking a tightrope through a
political and religious storm but it
looks like the movie tries to humanize
Paul with some light-hearted dialogue
in the trailer Paul reunites with Gurney
Paul and Gurney are close friends in the
book in the first movie it seems like
Duncan is Paul's best friend but in the
book Gurney is his favorite Gurney now
has longer hair and Paul has blue eyes
which is caused by exposure to spice
over time so it looks like months or
years have passed Paul and Gurney have
both struggled to survive on this alien
world separate from their friends and
familiar faces so it's emotional when
these two reunite after their time apart
Paul and Gurney are confronted by how
much they've both changed this reunion
is also a nice scene in the 80s David
Lynch Dune movie with Gurney played by
Patrick Stewart later we see Gurney
facing Beast raban Gurney was once a
slave of the harkinons rabban destroyed
Gurney's family and gave Gurney the scar
on his face so Gurney Wants Revenge the
dune book never tells us exactly what
happens to base Rabanne in the end but
it looks like the movie may give us a
dramatic clash between these old enemies
this could be a good opportunity to show
off Gurney's fighting skills because in
the book Gurney is one of the most
skilled Warriors in the universe it also
looks like Paul faces rabban at one
point so there's a bunch of new Rabanne
stuff in this movie and raban does not
look ready director Villeneuve says that
there's something touching about raban
he wants to please the baron but he's
not very intelligent he doesn't have the
brain for this war that said there are
hints in the books that rabban may be a
little smarter than he seems so they
could also play with that in the movie
stillger is in charge of a group of
fremin he's the naib of Siege to beer he
is a strong intelligent leader but now
he's becoming a follower of Paul in the
trailer Jessica asks do you believe in
Paul and stilgar says there are signs
stilgar is impressed that Paul rides
this huge sand worm and that Paul killed
jamus in the first movie in the trailer
he raises a knife for Paul fanatically
and he says I don't care what you
believe I believe it looks like stilgar
believes that Paul is the lisan al-gayib
the prophesied leader who will save the
foramen and we see strength and passion
in stilgar's faith but it's also kind of
tragic and wrong because the listen
al-ghaib prophecy was made up by the
Bene jesuret to manipulate the framing
Paul says it's not a prophecy it's just
a story Jessica says the prophecy gives
the fremin hope but Paul says that's not
not hope Paul does have real power he
has Visions he may be the quizzes had
Iraq Giga brain but the prophecy of Paul
saving the fremen is a lie Dune explores
what it means to believe the impact of
religion on cultures and on people so
how will Faith change stillger Gurney
says that it's good that the fremen
think Paul is a messiah he says to use
that power but Paul is reluctant because
he has visions of a terrible holy war an
Unstoppable tide of violence sweeping
Across the Universe with him at its
Center Gurney says Paul is scared of
losing control but Paul says he's scared
of gaining control Paul worries that his
choices could bring disaster and it's
hard because Paul's Visions are
uncertain they're always changing and
shifting like in the first movie Paul
had a vision of Jamis being his friend
and a vision of Charney stabbing and
those things didn't happen Paul's
Visions don't always come true they're
just possible Futures so in the book
Paul is haunted by these terrible
Visions trying to use them to survive
but also trying to prevent the holy war
you can see the Visions in tune as a
metaphor for our own hopes and fears
plans and predictions there are dangers
in trying to make our dreams come true
Paul asks if Charney believes in him
because when Paul plays the role of a
leader and Messiah to the fremant
Charney looks angry chani says this
prophecy is how they enslave us she sees
the truth that the prophecy is a lie
meant to exploit the foramen chani says
she's not fighting for Paul she fights
for her people and this is a change from
the book in the book Johnny doesn't
question the prophecy she's a mostly
passive character who just supports Paul
the book does explore how wrong it is
that the Atreides use prophecy to
manipulate the fremin but that's mostly
done through the thoughts of Paul and
Jessica it looks like the movie makes
this theme more explicit by having
Charney loudly reject the exploitation
of her people but at the same time the
Charney criticizes muadib the Messiah
chani loves Paul Paul says I will love
you as long as I breathe and Paul and
Charney cry together crying is a
powerful sacred act to the foramen
because crying wastes moisture when
frame and culture is about conserving
moisture crying is called giving water
to the dead so this is an intense
emotional scene Paul says I will do what
must be done so what terrible choices or
sacrifices must he make that he and
chani weep for the dead and how will
they resolve the tension of Charney
opposing Paul's religion how does it
feel when your boyfriend is space Jesus
there's also a shot of Charney thumping
the ground with her fist it's like in
the first movie when kinds thumps the
ground to attract a sand worm
we see visions of Paul's mother Jessica
if Paul is the Messiah what is her
Destiny director of vilnov says Jessica
lost everything she is still grieving
the death of her partner later and the
loss of her home on Caledon but she's
also carrying New Life Jessica is
pregnant remember and Paul had a vision
of her baby in the first movie so
Jessica struggles to adapt to Iraqis but
she focuses on protecting her son and
unborn child in the book she believes
that they must use the fremin to secure
her family's future and we see more of
this ritual with this liquid the Water
of Life we see Jessica gasp with blue
eyes and see this old fremin woman
romalo this is called the ceremony of
the seed it's one of the great fremin
Mysteries and it is transformative what
will Jessica become then we see the
emperor of the universe shaddam Carino
played by Christopher Walken twenty
years ago Hawken was in a music video
that referenced Dune the lyrics walk
without Rhythm and it won't attract the
worm refers to dune's sandwalk so it's
funny that now Watkins in a dune movie
in all the big Dune adaptations the
emperor is played by older men but
that's not how he looks in the book in
the book shadam is 72 years old but he
looks like he's 35 presumably because
shaddam takes spice and spice extends
your life makes you live longer and look
younger in the book shadam is Slim and
elegant with a thin face and cold eyes
and he has red hair apart from the hair
shadam looks a lot like Paul's father
later because their cousins the Atreides
and Carinos are related lato has dark
olive skin in the book and shaddam's
Grandson is saturnine so shadam probably
also has dark olives skin in the book so
Christopher Walken does not look like
the 35 year old dark-skinned redhead
described in the book but what about his
personality who is shaddam Carino as
Emperor shaddam appears to be the most
powerful man alive in the book he wears
military sadaka uniforms to show his
strength he acts confident arrogant
wrathful and demanding like a man who
must be obeyed but shaddam is not as
powerful as he seems because the
emperor's power is limited by the Benet
Jesuit shaddam's wife Anna rule is a
Bene Jesuit all his children are Bene
jesuret trained and the benejeret
control should arm's reproduction they
don't let him have a son the benejeret
plan to put a benejeret on the throne
after shaddam and the spacing Guild also
have influence on shaddam so while
shaddam acts like he's all powerful he
doesn't have control of his succession
or of his own reproduction iriland
writes that he was a man fighting
constantly to escape the bars of an
invisible cage so all shaddam's
pretensions to power the Pomp and pride
and fury is impotent and pathetic you
get a sense of that helplessness from
shaddam's slumped posture in the trailer
here he and his daughter iralan play a
board game with little pyramids the Dune
book mentions a game called pyramid
chess or chiops named after the real
Egyptian pharaoh who built the Great
Giza Pyramid pyramid chess is a nine
level game about putting the king in
check and putting the queen at the Apex
which is a nice metaphor for shaddam
shaddam is like a king in Chess because
he's not a very powerful piece it's the
Queen the Benet Jesuits who have the
real power in this game so we might
imagine that irelan is winning this game
against her father they play in a
beautiful sunlit garden this is probably
the Carino Planet kaitan this
comfortable leafy environment is a
contrast to the harsh deserts of arrakis
to the foramen this Garden would be an
unimaginable Paradise in the book
shaddam indulges in the Pomp and
opulence of Court he flaunts his wealth
with useless luxury and fancy events he
sits on a massive Throne carved of fiery
quartz from the jewel planet and this
luxury is important because the book
explores how Indulgence can make you
weak the 1984 Dune movie captured this
opulence well but in this new trailer we
don't see any fancy luxury shaddam and
his attendants wear simple plain clothes
hopefully other scenes will rise up
shaddam's drip in the tree trailer
Ireland tells shaddam that Paul is still
alive and chidam says to deal with this
Prophet which perhaps leads to irulan's
investigation plotline hinted at in the
first trailer none of that is in the
book it looks like the movie is creating
new scenes to explore shaddam and erilan
more in the trailer shaddam says that
Paul's father later was weak which is an
odd thing to say because shaddam
attacked later because he was worried
about lato's strength the book says that
shaddam feared later and that he also
respected later Saddam wished that later
had married his daughter iralan so that
later could have been his son-in-law so
when shaddam calls later weak maybe he
does that out of spite and envy and
frustration projecting his own weakness
onto later shaddam is a complex
character a man of terrible wrath and
superficial charm and sad impotence
hopefully Christopher Walken captures
these layers to the emperor at the end
of the trailer we see this reflective
spherical orb which looks like the
Imperial spaceship in the first June
movie so this orb may be shaddam's ship
and the structure beneath it is this
metal tent glimpsed in the big battle
scene we see more of fade rather
harkenen fighting in an arena we see
Fades two blades in the book fade has a
black glove holding a long knife and a
white glove holding a short poisoned
knife but the baron looks down on his
nephew fade and says show me who you are
because the fights in June are all about
revealing your potential through focus
and challenge what is fade capable of
and what are The Baron's plans for fade
we see fade fighting Paul another black
and white Duality between a hearken and
Beast and a mindful a tradies this shot
of fade raising his knife matches this
shot of Paul raising his knife in some
ways fade and Paul are alike they are
both the young heirs to ancient houses
and they are both products of the Benny
Jesuit breeding program in the book The
Benny Jesuit planned for Jessica to have
a daughter not a son and that daughter
was going to marry fade and their child
together was meant to be the super
powerful quizat's hadarak but instead
Jessica had a son and now that sun is
fighting the man who he was kind of
meant to marry which is a disaster for
the benejeret plan so what happens when
these two powerful opposites Clash Fades
knife pointing at Paul's face looks just
like the gomja bar and the hunter Seeker
another deadly challenge we see Paul
thump his chest with his fist just like
how jamus thumped his fist Paul
remembers the lessons of the foramen in
the trailer Paul raises his knife to a
huge crowd of fremin and he shouts long
live the fighters he says this in the
fremin language that was invented for
these movies by David J Peterson
Peterson also created the Valyrian and
Dothraki languages for Game of Thrones
but in the Dune book these words are
different the phrase meaning long live
the fighters
isada which is Loosely based on real
Arabic the author Frank Herbert seems to
have got this phrase from a 1961 article
about the Algerian War when Algeria won
independence from the French the article
describes a leader raising a hand over a
crowd and they Roar Yahya chauhada which
the article says is Arabic for long live
the fighters the June book published
just a few years later has an extremely
similar scene stillgar raises a knife
over a crowd and they Roar yah ya
chauhada Frank even uses the same words
as the article throng and raw this
translation and anglicization of the
Arabic is not very accurate but the
point is that this line in the book is
inspired by real Arabic and by a real
war between Muslim Freedom Fighters and
European colonists which has
similarities to the fremin fighting the
hakunans Frank was also inspired by a
book about Muslims in the Caucasus
fighting the Russian Empire and by
Lawrence of Arabia with the Bedouin
Frank Drew from many different Arabic
North African and Islamic cultures to
create the fremin and the Dune book
makes this explicit in their language
the fremin used lots of Arabic and
Islamic terms including Ramadan burkas
Sharia and the Hajj the new movies
include some Arabic words like lisan
al-ghaib Shai hulud Mahdi and muadiba
all Loosely based on Arabic but the
movies also make changes to remove
Arabic words like in the book Paul has
visions of a Jihad but the movie is just
call this whole holy war changing the
words for long live the fighters is
another example of the movies removing
and minimizing the Arabic and Islamic
roots of June so Dune part 2 makes
changes from the book it adds more fight
scenes and explosions it adds new scenes
with irelan and shaddam and rabban and
it creates tension between Charney and
Paul but this trailer does focus on the
central theme of the book the danger of
political and religious Messiahs so
hopefully this movie will capture the
heart and meaning of tune
we'll make more Dune videos after the
next movie comes out for now we're
working on a big video about Jon Snow if
you'd like to support alt shift X making
these videos check out our patreon live
stream tier patrons can watch hours of
behind the scenes content about the Jon
Snow video and June videos patrons get
videos early and can also join the
patron only Discord remember to
subscribe to the alt shift X podcast on
YouTube and Spotify and podcast apps we
will have more episodes soon and you
might like the alt shift X audio feed
podcast which has audio versions of all
shift x videos links are below thanks
for watching shout out to patrons Rory
shruthers Rosemary Walsh Lindsay Kyle
and magic and alien man cheers
[Music]